THE OWCRISIS .T BIDEID
WILL ME TROOO NATOD S  EARN EUR
SSIANS WOULD
BE, QUORRIFIC.
P TRY'S PRESIDENT URGES .
RUSSIA IS ONING NEW  O UAT
BORDER, THCCORDINIOR DEFSE OFFIA
OFUS ANTIAL G NALL
>>OL HILL REPUBLD ,
WOULDING TNG TACROMISEA LARGO DS
>>> I WANT TO BEGIN WITH A E TH
P E FOREIGN
RANKING ERISCH OF PUATIC CHAIRME
IDAHO.
HIMORNING.I'LLNK YOU FOR
WE HAVE HEARD ST
WAIT U OF T  TO STOP THOSE DIRE
AT UKRAINIANS -- A WHAT G SOERE?
>> GOOGOOD TO BE
FRIEND ANDIMISCH
I THINK PRESIDENT ZEINICSI.
VAA RLY HEUSORE POSS INVASION O
ALREADY AND CRIMEA AND WLA
EASTE UKRAINE.
ANCE OF S TES TO HIS ECONOMY WHI
M AS WELL. I UNDERSTANTHAT.END E
14$650LI BECAU0,00
RU
THREE DIFFERENT PARTS OF
SSDED YO TAKE SERIOUSLY HE
POTENTIAL FOR ANREAL.
BE T THE UKRAINIANS TO
OMIC NEEDSL TO DTHEMES,  T
THEY HAVAT,  I
ETRWARD.
DO YOU ANY WHICH
RUSSIAHOO INVA AT
POINT?
THA LOT OFS THAT BELIEVE, IF PU
HE SEES INDECISION, HE WILKE
ADNT
ME SION TO DO THAT YET.
WHAT BOB A AND OUR COALITIN SENS
ATTEMPTING TO DO PROJECT
THE SO AS S TO SEE THADO THAT, D
PROJECT THE STRENGTH
AND CONVINCE HIMT THIS WOULD
Y, VEA
ITNG T EXTREMELY
IS NOME ACRIMEAWHEN HE DID THIE
TH,
SUNTY MORELDWIDE
PO TO HIS THOUGHTS THIS TIME.
>> LALK ABOU
JUSTTIONEDNAR RISCH,
CHAIRM MZ, YOU'R
WORKING TOGETHER.
OF YOUSCUSSION, BIIS
O TOGETHER
N RUSSIA.
E E WRITTETHE ALHELP.SOOW AREO T
SENATOR RISCHND I N  OUR
COLLEAGUES, A
BIPARTISAN COALITION BOT
FOREIGRELATIONS COMMITTED
COMMITTEE IN
AN INTENSIVE
E  1 CRIBE IUGH
SUCCESSFUL.WHAT THE I
ERANDIBLPA
RESOLVE FOR SUPPOR UKRAINEAND E
EQUSSI IT
INVADESOCASES FOR WHAT IT HAS .
SO WARE DEVISING, BUILDING UN TO
L THMOIONS, IS ELEMENTS,VE
SAAINST IFICANBANKS,PPO
ONIN
TERMS OFTO THEIR
ACCOUN PENSIONS, MOR
ASSISTATOKR
AT SECTORARUSSIA'SECACTING ECONN
THESE ARE SANCON
WE HAVE EORE,
R ME >> SENATOR RISCH, Y GET 1H
ST TALKED
AB
SPECIFICALLY, IF I
THE FACT THAT YOPUSA.
N ADST, TH AFTER
INVAONAY THAT'DETERRENT.
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO COMPROMISE
ON THAT?
>> FIRST OF NK BOB'S
RIOD
SCHAPPENED
DAYS.HERE . BEEN A -HA-AS
IFGS OMOST WH THESE , DIFFERIDH.
PROBLEM, YOU CAN RESOLVE ONE, S,
TO THELINE. YO
YOU WILL THERE.
>> WIN
I'M MOREHAN CAUTIOUSLY STIC AT
WHEN WE GED.C.
E ORD I KNOW BOB  THAT HOPEAL.
GONTEF AFTERN
LOOK, THERE ANCTIONS TOR RISCH..
Y COP CAUSE OF WHAT RUSSIA HAS
ALREADRARAINE,G ERATIONSS TO
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT
ARES OTIONS THAT COULD TAKE PLA
NOW.
BUT THENTATINGD
H RUSSIA'S ECONOMYD THE
COUIWE
GOINTO SS PUTIN
HA DECIDMANY
US TO RUSSIA.
THS THAT
WOUL LAT
VA SCT
N
ALAILL
TRAVEL NO MATTER WHAT.
>>SCH,
THED STREAM 2 WERMANY,ION IS
RELUCTANT TO TO
BLOCK THAT
WILL YOU HAVTHIS
LE
>>U KNE D A
DISAGREEMENT ON THAT, A
AGREEMENT ON THAT, IK OFFICE, T
THAT T GER
THAT TY NG -- PAU WOD,
OR UNTIL LATE SUMMER IN ANOMONT
EVENT.
ATS THE OPRTRK WITH THAT IY WE
TH THEAST  IFORE W ACROSS TH CH
WHAT'SNO
SWIFL EM BANKS?
E AL NEED BE OTABLE.T CAT
ON OR CACA R,
HAVE APP EFFECT NOMY.BELIEVE GI
SA EXPEDIT
DELIVERY OF LETHAL
DEALING  T MISINFORMATION  RUSSS